ah okay I am here and you are here and
today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza in gray block pizza is
a special pizza establishment the kind
of place when you get there oh you're
gonna have a good time
it's at eighteen eleven Pico Boulevard
in Los Angeles on the way to the beach
gray block pizza get that hitter was
getting real it's getting real out there
isn't it some lady at the market was
yelling if you keep your sunglasses on
it can't get it why can't it can't get
in through your eyes and people are like
look [ __ ] chill out okay I'm trying to
get the last peach over here and she's
out if it can't get in through your ice
and I'm trying to maybe get I'm trying
to figure out how to make a dinner when
all they got left in the store is two
bottles of sparkling water you know some
pear some Perrier and a cup and a box of
Juji fruits I'm trying to figure out
okay am i cannot you know finesse that
enough to trick the kids into thinking
this is some kind of gumdrop soup or
something and this [ __ ] is in the virus
can't get into your face
so we wanted it all and we we got it
this is it and let's make the most of it
this is Spencer Jacob growl with
celebrate
[Music]
celebrate mess
we're gonna die let's have some fun
while we all die
[Music]
let's have some fun while we all die
that music huh nice to have a little
beat nice to have a little beat to get
you through something nice to have a
little beat to get you through something
hope I hope everyone is finds themself
well check-in check yourself check in
with yourself feel your legs feel your
arm feel your cousin bro
check his neck hey he's what does he
does he have that pulse okay he's good
Henry is good you know little Cheryl is
good okay all right all right
everybody's fine everybody's fine
there's a lot of you know there's
there's definitely something happening
there's something going on there's a lot
of reaction to it at the same time you
know there's definitely a there's a
fiddler on the roof you know you got
some you know you have some you got a
dirty bad boy with a frickin with a
sneaky violin you know strumming on some
people's DNA right now and that's corvid
19 who you think if you heard any other
year you hear corvid 19 you're thinking
that's somebody on um you know MaxPreps
or somebody that's gonna be a high
school all-american right there that's a
wide receiver
oh they got corvid 19 dude they're
probably gonna have to you know they're
gonna have to move the strong safety
over to help double-team but now it's a
disease now and it is it's getting some
people now I'm not look I'm not some
people are losing it and you start to
see who people are when this happens you
start to see oh okay oh okay Ronald
buried himself in his yard alright I see
how he is when a disease comes around oh
okay
Oh Bernadette bought a hot-air balloon
and now she's just hanging out up over
Memphis talking [ __ ] and throwing down
um you know uh you know empty bags of
bugles chips and talking [ __ ]
people have different ways of getting
away from it
if you cut off the news that definitely
helps you live I'll tell you that that
will help you live you know I've been in
Maui for the past week and I want to
thank everybody that came out to the
show over there man it's just Maui is
just amazing
it's a May it's just if you never you
know Mexico I love you know I love
Mexican food I love Mexican people the
but the beaches are good there but they
got glass in the sand baby
they got glass in the sand would you go
down to Maui oh you don't even know what
happen do you put your feet in the ocean
and it feels like the water just feels
like somebody's just just kind of I
don't want to say this but kind of just
kind of [ __ ] you're right between the
20 or toes brah that's how it feels
honestly and that's how what I do I
think it's just they have that vibe baby
it feels like a big huge [ __ ] gorilla
is just giving you a [ __ ] massage
from the inside of your body and that is
that's the rapture baby right there that
feels good and that's what's going on
over there in Maui I mean even though
the hitchhiker's have halos on you're
halfway to heaven you know you got some
dudes choking to death on something you
reach in his mouth and pull it out it's
a statue of baby Jesus right there some
dude got a bj in his throat because
you're halfway to heaven man
that kind of place if you haven't been
and that was uh that was really the last
show of the tour except for one more
coming up in Nashville and I see a lot
of other comedians I'm not going to name
names Chris D'Elia Brenda Chou you know
Bobby Lee cancelling their shows dude
but I'm telling you this my show April
17th in Nashville at the Ryman
Auditorium is still ago okay not like
these other B a and that means B a
chance
comedians my things that go
yeah the virus though people's freaking
people are freaking out we had somebody
call from the Maui show I'm gonna check
in with them real quick this call came
in to the hotline here we go just saw
your show tonight at Maui
oh hello raah and thank you for calling
raw and I appreciate your call homeward
and now we had special characters now he
has special characters I'll say that you
know everybody up there is they got
you'll see somebody they're growing on
half of their hair they'll have like
dreadlocks and then half of their hair
will have crops built into the side of
it they'll be growing wheat up half
their scalp just just really and the
other half the growing weed you know
that you'll have a dude you'll crack
open a coconut and inside there'll be a
homeless dude in there smoking DMT just
right here like dang damn man with the
how many calories are in this you know
they just say it's it's just they got a
lot of missing if you ask anybody got a
bunch of dudes named Patrick over there
that are missing sleeping in hammocks
some dude some guy got wrapped up in a
hammock fell asleep out in the Sun and
you saw the tan on his body it looked
like somebody liked his skin and just
Ben was made out of just latticework or
something just really
just insane just really baffling you got
a lot of people you know you have like a
lot of drum circles a lot of loose titty
meat flopping around you know and it's
just something special man and it's
beautiful it really is it's like going
halfway to heaven man
it's like going halfway to heaven if you
get a chance over there and they got
Birds over there - you'll see a bird you
never even seen nobody's seen him and
you some of the birds they act like
they're listening to what you're doing
or looking at you like and then fly off
to tell somebody that's a freaking
red-billed tattletale right there but
it's a wonderful place and I was so
grateful to be there and thank you guys
and I recommend it they're not tripping
about the virus over there they're not
tripping about the virus they're living
more in the regular world over there in
Maui's to the deep end of the earth baby
and and I love it
you know Mexico's great but they got
broken sand and aglaia they got glass in
the sand and they got glass in the sand
over there
so all right let's take this call right
here Apio is is Garrett from Nashville I
what's up Garrett and Garrett is also uh
it's like a word that means something
else to Garrett have you you know what
I'm saying have you heard about this
Garrett and it's also a name on word I
just really wanted to get your take on
how we're gonna beat this coronavirus
because honestly it's techne ever the
the world and I just want to see I
actually want to hear what you have to
say about how we're gonna beat it and I
want to hear your theories on it cuz
they're a bunch of them out there Gang
Gang love your podcast gets me through
the week really appreciate you brother
keep doing thing well thank you for the
question Garrett orga rot and
and look man can we beat it
Bob the Builder can't we beat it yes we
can brother yes we can beat this I mean
there's a lot going on with it
first of all yes I believe that the
media has made it out of proportion okay
I think they've made it bigger I think
people you know some of the networks use
it as a tool there's a lot of fear
tactics I do think that I also think
that you got to be you got to play ahead
of the ball game
if this is that Grim Reaper if this is
that dirty daddy that's gonna freaking
hot a knife inside of your inside of
your spleen then yeah you have to you
have to this is the only way to do it is
to warn people in advance and have them
prepare in advance you can't let things
like part of my brain says well you know
let's get a couple people to die you
know leather people you know people if
people die then we will see okay this
thing is for real you know right now it
just sounds like the flu and not even as
bad as the flu but if there's the
propensity for it to get extremely dirty
then then they have to do it this way
they have to warrant they have to warn
everybody now they have because once it
gets too late it would be hysteria so
really the way that things are being
done I think is the only way to do it
now with that said some people are
losing their [ __ ] like I was in the
elevator in my apartment building and I
could tell ahead and see my neighbor in
a while because I was in and you know
was out of the country I was in Maui and
I hadn't seen him and so he I could tell
he had his kid in his arms they just
came back from the park and he's a nice
guy we really get along well but I could
tell this time there was a little bit of
like okay let's see who's got it
you know let's show you know let's show
our bless show our bumps let's see who's
got it
and
could just tell man that any that
anything could be something else that
was a little different he didn't really
stay and communicate as long I was a
little bit uncertain so some people are
doing it like that also went and got a
Vietnamese massage bra or thigh
I got a thigh massage and look I don't
care what's going on dude for $35 an
hour I'll let a thigh dude beat my ass
up in the back you know beat my you know
beat the you know beat the gristle out
of my neck
and that's what I got I mean I got that
thing and he said it was slow in there
and I thought honestly I thought the
dude had been gay I've been going there
for about a year I thought he was uh you
know a little bit more on the boys boys
boys boys boys by Bowie's side but he
showed me a picture of his wife and
child and I was like oh wow you know he
was showing me something on his phone
and uh and then I saw a picture of a kid
I said hey you got a child he said yeah
I got the child so you know I had to you
know I just I said all right man I gave
him a nice tip and just I think that's
one thing we can do is be supportive of
people that we know are working in like
industries where we just got it we got
to even things out this is a way to help
each other survive you know it's like
right now if you have a little bit of
extra of something it's a good time to
share it it's a good time for to look in
people's eyes and and you know I think
finally humanity I think all of us in
some ways is a real opportunity for
Humanity right here but on the other
side man this [ __ ] is getting risky
shit's getting rescue man it could it's
like a you know it just could go either
way I'm gonna get Nick right here in the
studio we're gonna talk about it a
little bit more man so I'm not driving
alone because he'll people are so the
social distancing I mean it's hard
enough mm-hmm it's hard enough to get a
couple [ __ ] to hang out with you and
now even if you do get a chick to hang
out with you y'all got to be six feet
apart so now you got to get one of those
little like
you know you got to get some of those
you know those cafeteria mittens with
the plastic ones if you want to touch a
breast or do a um a butt rub or body rub
so I think it's you know it's two things
it's it's that yes it could be
overreaction at the same time the only
way to to be in front of a drastic
disease is to overreact you know you got
a plan ahead you have to there's no
other because if you plan behind damn it
sorry if you plan behind then that's not
that's no way to do it and that's no way
really to do anything you have to plan
ahead and with this many people alive it
you know I'm just it made me think a lot
of things it was like it made me think
like wow we're we're we're it just
changed suddenly everything really got
real slow I felt like and everything got
a lot smaller it was like okay we're
just okay where people were unsure like
yeah whenever that that that thing with
my neighbor it was just like okay we
usually would kind of shake hair or
communicate longer shake a hand or touch
each other's hand real fast even but we
this time there was a little bit of
little just you know it's like a kind of
square dancing but this [ __ ] what we
wouldn't square with each other it was a
little bit more dosey doe
but uh but dose II don't at the same
time you know it yet I will say this
though in Maui they did have one
haircutting guy who works on the hair he
works on the main strip in this town
called pie-pie a pea
um paia look if you are missing or
someone you know is missing or is
missing yeah that's where they are
okay Paia they got a lot you'll see a
dude wearing snow gear you know what I'm
saying with uh you know going by honest
gate ward at 200 miles an hour and
you'll see somebody else riding doing
piggyback you know riding piggyback on a
zombie over there and eating half of an
orange bro and splitting him with an owl
they got some real they got some people
up on that dust baby they got a lot of
dust bears out there but they had a man
over there and he was cutting hair so I
walked in because I have hair so I
walked in and he's a and he was giving
me oh he didn't I went to shake his hand
introduce myself and he gave me the UH
elbow like kind of put his elbow out you
know as if I gave her shaking somebody's
hand that doesn't have a hand or on or
bottom half of their arm and they just
give you their elbow and you just kind
of hold it for a second he did like that
he's like oh we got to be careful with
the virus and then he told me to come
back later that day he wanted to cut my
hair I'm like [ __ ] you ain't cutting my
hair did if you won't shake my hand you
think I'm gonna let you put your thick
grizzly mitts brother this was a thick
dude this was a thick dude he seemed
like kind of guy who would honestly even
have a little bite of my hair he seemed
like that kind of creepy dude while he's
back there cutting and he was cut a
little bit off and have it for himself
you know a little bit of head jerk you
just have a you know half a gram of a
sideburn or something but but yeah so
there's fear of the virus there's a lot
of things going on there's fear there's
reality the reality the numbers don't
stack up for me in the reality
Department you know it's like it's
killing less people then then something
normally would kill and then this is
what I don't like the news does the news
does this [ __ ] they say Oh a lot of
elderly people are dying from it and a
baby has it that's what they always do
Oh a baby has it Oh a baby has it and
then in the newsroom they'll somebody
will press a button and you'll hear like
a baby cry in the back just like the way
they add in sound effects you know and a
lot of elderly people have been dying
from it and also outside of Minnesota
a baby has it you're like what because
that's where they hook you every time
that's the fishhook a baby has it that's
how the news always get you when they
say a baby have the virus and then
you're like but what do we know about
this baby cuz they never show the baby
what do we know about this baby does
this but is this baby a legit baby you
know what I'm saying is he small and
incapable or is this a [ __ ] baby
that's you know he was with the Union
for a few want a few years and then he
jumped over to picket lines and he's
been smoking he doesn't give a [ __ ]
about himself he's got two other little
babies of his own who is this baby
because don't just hook me with the baby
line you know I'm just so sick of the
bait-and-switch of the of the oh you
know hooked me with this you know use
whatever they can to get me to believe
it Oh a baby has it what kind of baby is
this a baby who shaves and stuff is this
a baby who wearing turtlenecks and doing
have gold wristlets well who is this
baby who is he is this some little
Italian baby huh it's just maybe even
punching and beating his wife at night I
just want to know what's going on here
you know what I'm saying I just I just I
want more I want real information and
you can't get real information now the
news no that's a it's just such a crazy
time for something like this because who
believes the news and people are like
the world the world health order the
Center for Disease Control but then
other [ __ ] starts coming in you know
tremaine's a virus hut dot-com slash
data and people sharing that link well
what the [ __ ] is that
who's Tremaine you know it just it's
cysts there's a lot of false information
man there's a lot of false information
so I think we just have to trust our
instinct
you know I think it goes back to that
and we're getting to definitely put you
back more in like a vital place you know
I'm a little bit more concerned with who
what's going on with me am i healthy am
i taking care of myself it because look
we've been sucking we've been sucking on
the sweet salami of comfort for a long
time here in America we've been just
riding on the sugar sleigh of softness
we're soft man people have shirts people
have shirts and jackets people have
shirts jackets hoodies and earmuffs oh
you okay
okay we've been living a soft existence
and there's two you know halves to every
coin baby and that's why you know
something the other side of the hammer
is gonna hit you in the head and that's
what some of this is it could be Mother
Nature saying alright Oh are y'all gonna
y'all want to do all the juice boxes
and fantasy football then I'm about to
show up I'm not to show up with my big
tits and show y'all who is boss that
could be what's going on see if I can
get Nick in here I want to just get a
group thought on it we're also going to
get into the calls about heaven we had
um response as to what different
people's heaven is we had responses to
the dating cousin dating and how that
looks and how that plays out if you get
involved in it so we want to get into
some of that and also want to let you
know that today's episode brought to you
by blue chu but before that also one
lets you know happy st. Patrick's Day
this week and uh I knew [ __ ] was getting
real because on the Irish Times dot-com
which I believe is a reliable Irish
website out of Dublin coronavirus
government calls on all pubs and bars to
close
and that is as of yesterday so you know
something's going on when the Irish are
setting down their cups today's episode
is brought to you by and sponsored by
blue Chu
remember the old days when you were
always ready to go remember that
remember running down the hallway and
just you fall down and just you just get
back up and you're erect remember that
remember that you'd be outside and a
bird would come and just land on your
wiener
Oh remember that blue ChiCom that's blue
like the color blue you can increase
your sexual performance and get that
extra confidence in bed with blue Chu
blue true brings you the first chewable
with the same fda-approved active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis you can
take them anytime do it in whatever
you're going to jail pop one bra you
know what I'm saying nobody know
straight men are gonna beat up the guy
in jail who has an erection not gonna
happen
show up hard baby and do your time you
can take them day or night you can take
them on a full stomach
you just had half a pizza who gives a
damn bruh get erect and since they're
chewable they work up to twice as fast
as a pill she can be Rinna well you can
be ready whenever an opportunity arises
dude you want to jump out of a moving
vehicle and hopefully bang somebody by
the time your body comes to being still
from rolling from the inertia take one
jump out they act fast blue chew is
prescribed online by licensed physicians
so you don't have to go to the doctor's
office or wait in a line at the pharmacy
and it ships right to your door in a
discreet package they're made in the USA
and since blue two prepares and ships
direct they're cheaper than a pharmacy
and best of all there's no more
awkwardness right now we've got a
special deal for this past weekend
listeners look you're at home there's
nothing going on support the podcast get
erect visit blue chu dot-com and get
your first shipment free when you use
our special promo code
th EO just pay five dollars shipping
again that's BL you e CH e w.com
promo code Theo to try it for free blue
chu is the better cheaper faster choice
and we thank you for sponsoring the
podcast oh yo remember the guy that I
hitchhiked with I picked up last time
that hitchhiker I saw him again my boy
just sigh out there and Maui
I met a beekeeper out there man that
runs a apiary they made me that
beautiful bread somebody got me a nice
hat what else
half the staff over there by the Four
Seasons you know a lot of beautiful
fellows and young men out there
ukulele bad boys they showed up um just
a lot of people out of just I met just
so many nice people it was just it was
special
let's get Nick in here ain't it can you
hear me yeah I got it man thanks for
coming in bro oh yeah yeah we're just
talking just talking about the
coronavirus and what's goin on and let's
get into some of the the calls that came
in man and then I want to get in I'm
gonna get into the heaven responses and
stuff about coven people Dayton family
dating within the family cool all right
let's get into a couple of these calls
hey Co this is Dan from Lancaster
Pennsylvania love the show I'm putting
on years old I've been with my my
current wife for about three years now
we met in college
been together for almost nine years um
things have been going really great so
we had a norm really normal life
couple months ago we started trying for
a family and the thing that's kind of
really went this [ __ ] around that she
kind of really started getting distant
she eventually told me that she never
wanted a family she went back on birth
control behind my back and long story
short she ended up cheating on me with
one of her co-workers Jesus Christ sorry
brother sorry to interrupt your life
there with the Lord but it sounded like
you could use a little of it uh she's
about to burn his house down yeah yeah
I'm afraid to listen anyway anymore this
call man I hope you're staying safe out
there from the virus overt and then he
recently moved out of our house and
we're currently has been separated for
about a couple months now so I thought a
few months a couple weeks now think
about everything and I'm just really
really confused on probably where to go
next
in my life I don't know if I want to
give her a second chance
or if I just kind of want to move on
with my life since we have such
fundamental differences oh yeah man I'm
an even just gonna I think you just have
to move on do not give that woman a
second yes dude a second chance for you
is a last chance a second chance for her
is a last chance this is could be where
you could be calling from an ICU next
time you could be Coleman from a burn
bvu burn victim unit you could be
calling from a fire I mean you could be
calling yam and I don't think that lady
I don't think that lady wants to be
around you dude not in a bad way you
sound like a good guy but it seemed like
she if she's seeing somebody else she
doesn't want a family and what else did
she do those were the big two but I mean
it sound like she lied to him for years
about wanting to have a family yeah even
even if she didn't cheat which is like a
pretty horrible thing to do someone you
care about the fact that he wants kids
and she doesn't I feel like as an
initial deal-breaker yeah that's it man
that's a deal-breaker because otherwise
and you're gonna have to be pretending
that kids are yours when you're at the
park you're gonna have to be you're
gonna have to get a dog and name it like
a kid named you know here's mark our dog
you know so that kind of [ __ ] is gonna
be a way buzzkill you know you can have
a kids room and nobody you're not gonna
have anybody in there you're gonna go
sleep in there sometimes at night that's
just gonna be it's a downhill life
you're looking for you're looking into
so I think your best move is to move on
man let's take this next one here we go
see ya this is the kratom K callin just
quit my job kratom King Coleman and
kratom is that thing it's kind of a
bootleg drug Hana
is this chin to chin quick king in the
state but because it caught he's the
first person I ever heard doing critten
doing a lot of crater was he really he's
still on it
Wow he looks the same I guess he looks
yeah he looks he looks I mean he could
be on it I guess you can't tell him
people are on it again [ __ ] trying to
get into like other things the only
thing I was wondering what are some
moments that you have had so just sort
of like push it to your ass and you have
to do something different when did you
know that it was time for a change yeah
man thanks for the call brother uh I
think he well you gotta be working you
know you always have to be working I
think you know I used to live with a
fella for the a friend of mine for a
while and his dad used to eat Tostitos
and stuff at night and he wouldn't you
know ever really talk to us and stuff
and he played tennis a lot but he always
say he said you yeah you have to have a
job you got to be working so the rest of
your stuff you can kind of figure that
out you know you can you can decide
within that within that world of of
having some sort of occupation what you
want to do but first I would go get a
job and then I would make a decision on
what you want to do because that's
really the only way that it works you
can't really do it the other way because
then you're just not doing [ __ ] you're
just kind of thinking about doing stuff
and you'll feel better too once you have
a job when she starts showing up for a
little bit of time a little bit of
commitment to work and having to do
stuff you're gonna feel a little bit
more in like you'll just feel a little
more inspired so I feel like that's what
I'll do you think that's what he's
talking about yeah I just kind of grew
it was a bad probably a bad move too
impulsively quit your job without
something else lined up although
ironically I did that when I moved out
here he did yeah I just kind of quit and
moved out here where were you working it
it was called Meister MMA it was a guy
he like imported sporting goods from
like overseas and they branded him as
his own mixed martial arts equipment
that's actually when I got into mixing
shark's cousin Zelda gyms and stuff and
it was cool but it was just like low
ceiling I was like this guy's first
employee started a business he's killing
it like if you go on Amazon you search
hand wraps at Meister MMA is the number
one thing that comes up there he crushes
and so I did a lot of shipping and then
also like cold calling to gyms because
we had wholesale so it was cool I really
liked it but it was just like I don't
know I I went to college for four years
and it just didn't seem like a future I
would always be like this guy's number
two
whereas I don't think he was like he was
more motivated have like a lifestyle
brand like where he had something just
going he could kind of live his life he
was gonna grow some huge conglomerate so
yeah just it was a ceiling for you yeah
hmm yeah I think man you got to get into
a place where at least you have a
ceiling first and then find a different
Avenue I mean or if you want to chase a
dream I think that's fine but you just
have to be doing it mhm so I think when
do you get to a place where you kind of
met your edge well I mean I think I
think getting to that place and when
you're working and staying busy is a
better place to be there then then
trying to find that place right now when
you're not working one thing I did when
I was working at the job and I was like
just searching for something I was
really passionate about I got a job at
Acme comedy club in Minneapolis on
nights I mean it paid like minimum wage
you were just doorman but like I didn't
meet people kind of in the industry that
I still now will cross paths with and
like that was an immediate future like I
wasn't girl with acne but I went towards
my passion kinda and then I didn't
notice at the time it didn't lead to
something directly but now because I did
that back in the day it has helped going
forward hmm so just I think just always
trying to be around things you care
about even it's not exactly what you're
trying to do yeah that's a great point
man yeah fine if there's something that
you're really passionate about if you
know what that is then yeah maybe start
somewhere small within that world you
can definitely get somewhere big within
that world you know sometimes it just uh
yeah getting close to the world he could
he could work at a head shop that sells
kratom yeah there you go man yeah start
your the [ __ ] kratom King dude what do
you mean
you know get a lawnmower and go cut a
crop but I was slang a few sacks all
right let's take another call here in
Oklahoma man I was going to ask you I'm
also sober I've been sober for years on
March 22nd but uh where do you go to
meet women now in sobriety like you know
I don't go out to the bar anymore and I
don't know man it's kind of hard hard to
be in your mid-thirties single and
trying to stay sober so well look
brother Congrats on the sobriety and
congrats on working that path I think
the the I think options are as you know
options are places where there's other
people you know you know you got a try
like church is good you know if you like
or some sort of religious environment
yoga gym you know a gym is sometimes
like just like a bar but with no liquor
really you know I know and some of them
have TVs but you know maybe through a
friend or meet a sober woman go to some
mixed meetings I know it's not as easy
but I think the value of the person that
you'll meet the actual connection could
really be there because then you
otherwise you meet somebody at a bar
it's just I mean the truth I think is is
you know
iin dedup meeting who I was brave enough
to meet that's what it was if like like
I feel like you end up with the girl
you're brave enough to talk to that's
what I feel like a lot of times um so
you could be brave enough anywhere you
can prepare a van I thought a barbecue
brave enough on a street you know go up
to a girl and say hey what's going on
you know are you you know do you know
somebody you know a guy named Patrick
and she's like yeah think so and then
they start talking to her the first part
is that hardest part how to break that
ice so Nick yeah I mean that's that's
great advice like just use is it I think
so okay I what you liked what you said
about like
the girl that like you meet that pushes
you to like go out on a limb I think
that it'll happen because you're that
motivated also I'll say the apps oh yeah
I think it's easier for a guy on those
dating apps to find a relationship
rather than just a hook-up than it is a
girl to find a real relationship like a
gut cuz like most guys on their just
going for the easy hookup so if you are
the guy that's looking for the
relationship girls who are looking for a
relationship will gravitate towards you
where you point where's the opposite
girls just completely they're just
constantly accosted by just dudes who
want to hook up so they probably give up
but the ones that are there are and go
on like more hinge than tinder okay yeah
tinder seems dangerous a lot of hookers
on there and robots and everything they
said um what else man let me get into
one more call here what we got Nick here
hey Thea its Jason from Southern
California what's up Jason thank you for
hitting the sub brother and I just got
back from Maui so if I sound like a
little beachy that's why I'm 22 I'm
story short the past couple months said
then noticing I've been losing a lot of
hair you know I'm not started to freak
me out I went to the doctor I said
everything's normal
you know but um I can tell that you know
I only got a few more years with my hair
that's not that better now but you know
I just it's been kind of hurting my
self-confidence part of me just wants to
be like you know who cares but then I
getting these you know weak moments
where it just feels like that's
everything I don't know just feel like
can't beat it you know so I just want to
hear your thoughts on you know how to
approach changes that are going on that
you don't want you know they don't look
good but on and how to you know stay out
of those weak moments
yeah man I feel you dude you know it's
hard for me to talk cuz I kind of you
know I've had hair taken out of the back
and put in the front you know I saw have
some extra hair twice yeah twice good
call
so but I do notice that when I focus on
my hair and then I start to really think
oh I'm losing my hair I'm losing my hair
whereas when I just when I'm having fun
and enjoying life then I don't think
about my hair at all and I'm just having
fun I think a lot of times it's worse in
our perception and the more we dote on
it then the reality of it also one of
the most attractive women I've ever seen
in my life
was married to the baldest looking dude
I ever seen and he was not really
wealthy and [ __ ] just blew my mind bro
so you know I think that you know I
think there's there's still you know
this took me a lot of options for women
you know they got a hat
I think toupees are gonna come back I
know that sounds crazy but things kind
of go in cycles and they've been out of
like style for about 70 years so it's
definitely time and then also there's a
lot of there's a there's a you can look
good and be bald these days I think you
have to kind of go to the gym or get
some glasses like you have to go with
like kind of a nerdy bald look or the
like you know the Joe Rogan bald look
you have to go with one or the other but
I think you can you could really work
bald it just takes reading or going to
the gym so I think it's just like
anything you're gonna have to find some
ways to maybe make up for it but I think
just working on the confidence is really
the biggest key finding ways to just
stay confident and I would just look at
bald dudes that have wives you know a
lot of times if women is kind of the
thing that you're worried about but yes
having hair all that great I don't know
I mean I think it's cool but I think
that sometimes it's kind of bothersome
to you always have to fix it whereas if
you could be bald and look decent you
could do whatever you want you know you
could get a job doing anything really
could work outdoors you could work
indoors
yeah what you got Nick the gym was like
my first thought initially like you're
you have something you think is making
you look worse that you can't control so
do something in your control that you
can make yourself look better and yeah
then it just kind of evens out if you
get a little Jack but lose your hair I'm
going through I'm pretty hair annoyed
right now I think are you I think it's
like going up I don't know like you said
I'm just trying not to think about it
but yeah maybe one day I'll be be
pulling out of the back I don't know but
it scares me I just try to think about
it like like the buck coronavirus yeah
yeah to give is don't think about it and
stay alive right now I think chicks are
gonna [ __ ] anybody that's alive so
that's the number one thing you got
going for you right now hey got some
rations yeah hey I'm living I got
something at the house you know so there
we go man that's all I got for you bro
thanks Nick for helping us out no
problem
good times hope I'm here next week ya
know in the podcast life okay a lot yeah
yeah man that's true dude I hope you're
here too man it's been uh
if this is the end man it's been a
[ __ ] run bro it's been good times
good times
I know be crazy huh dude I noticed
though like say I look like this morning
I was kind of like just touching my eye
for a minute and I wouldn't do anything
that I normally wasn't doing but my
brains like holy [ __ ] man are you you
bout to die or like I went and you press
the elevator button and I was like how
many people other people have touch this
it's it's just crazy how the paranoia
starts to become like a thing you know
yeah I walked up the stairs I was
breathing a little heavy house like oh
no I'm always out of shape awesome man
all right take care brother
and if you can't take care of yourself I
know who can and that's better help this
episode is brought to you by better help
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist you know it's a
way especially now with the virus and
people you know dying and people not
dying people staying indoors there's a
lot going on and so one thing you may
need is mental health help and one place
to get that is
through better help this service is
available for clients worldwide there's
a broad range of expertise in better
helps counselor Network which may not be
locally available in many areas you can
log into your account anytime and send a
message to your counselor you'll get
timely and thoughtful responses plus you
can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions so you won't ever have to sit
in an uncomfortable waiting room better
help is committed committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so they make it easy and free to change
counselors if needed better help wants
you to start living a happier life today
visit better help.com slash Theo that's
better
heelp and join the over 500,000 people
taking charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional and a special offer for
this past weekend listeners get 10% off
your first month at better help.com
slash Theo oh yeah
the virus is amongst us man what happens
what happens if this is where we go this
is where we stay what happens if this is
if we start having to just really
seclude ourselves what happens you know
there's a part of me that's revert that
is very exciting too you know part of me
is very like oh it makes me feel alive
as a being it makes whoever I am inside
kind of like yawn and wake up like oh
okay
we're not just cattle being herded
there's an you know we're gonna we're
about to see who's smart enough we're
about to play a real game here there's a
little bit of that in this there's a
little bit of that survival technique
there's a little bit of that what do I
do here what do I do now there's a
little bit of that in there there's also
a little bit of a chance to help other
people you know you know somebody's
going to be struggling you know you have
more you know it's a chance to give it's
a chance to share and those are things
that make us feel good you know those
are things that build bridges with
people and build connection you know
it's really a beautiful time to be able
to do that and to recognize the value of
that so that's pretty interesting what
else am I thinking about this virus you
know I don't know I've been in the store
yet so I'm just probably gonna pop by on
my way home and see if there's some
stuff in there
it may be miserable I may have to make a
soup you know I did hear that at the
toilet paper section it was all gone and
then somebody put cotton balls there
which I thought was kind of a kind of a
sweet idea I thought they're pretty
sweet bra if you just want to you know
if you just really want to wipe small
just aim small miss small you know we
had a couple calls that came in you know
the last solo episode I was talking
about the corona know about Jesus about
heaven and what's going on and and what
people thought of heaven when they were
young and what do they think of it now
is they're older and we had some calls
that came in so I wanted to uh to check
some of those out here we go crystal
from Virginia my idea of heaven when I
was little was living a shopping mall
those miss with Toys R Us was towards
miss but like a petting zoo oh damn okay
crystal so and you talk you talking fast
you might you something might be on a
little bit of crystal but uh hopefully
not hopefully you're doing great um so
yeah little toys are us on a petting zoo
I could see a child really loving that
there's just toys and animals and fun
things everywhere oh yeah right but now
that I'm older I feel like it's more
into class circle I think I mother
screwed up that word but you know what I
mean like I feel like we'll get
permission to explore the universe like
we just be out here flipping our souls
just be able to go to whatever whatever
planet they want maybe each plan it's a
little bit different a little bit of
visible a little bit of fifth
dimensional you know mm-hmm maybe
different like it's not earthly but it's
it might have like this plan it'd be
like this and this plan would be kind of
like I'm using the parts different than
using a cart so now I just feel like
it's just like
maybe there are aliens but they are not
visible to our human bodies maybe we had
to be a spirit to see them Wow
yeah I like that it's still kind of a
petting zoo it's just you're like
petting the universe with your spirit
you just kind of just cruising around
it's like this open-hearted kind of like
just being and you just kind of bump or
just bumping off the the walls of other
s Ilan's I think that sounds pretty
magical really yeah it's funny how when
you're young and then as you get older
the way that you could really envision
heaven and what it could seem like to
you I love that petting zoo though I
love a pony I love a small animal and
I've always really loved a small a small
animal homeward let's hear another call
hey Theo
my name's Spencer I'm from Georgia hey
Spencer thank you for calling man and I
hope you're saying healthy out there
gang and you're talking about what
heaven was like when we were children
versus works like now and I was thinking
about heaven when I was a child and how
my dad told me that when you die you go
to heaven you get to live forever and
ever and ever and it gave me like a
weird sinking feeling the side of me
like you never die it just goes on
forever and ever and ever in this place
and there's never gonna be a stop to it
yeah it seems like a lot it does seem
like a loan it does seem like a long
haul especially as a child I can imagine
it seemed like a long haul
onward so when I was a child I used to
think about that too easy to scare me
but then when I got older I thought
about it and thought like well maybe
heaven is a place where we can exist
forever and at some point we choose to
come down here into this dimension and
feel like that we're living but we can
die so we can learn something with each
trip that we take down here we get to
learn things about ourselves and reality
and stuff man that's really interesting
yeah like like heaven is kind of the
it's like the
car place and then our bodies are like
you know earth or you know existence is
sort of each time you get rented and you
get to take out you go out and you have
an experience and you go back and they
either return you with a full tank or
they return you on empty you know they
might return you a couple of dents and
the doors anything but yeah you have an
experience and then you go back and like
kind of park back into the shop that's
pretty yeah I really like that man
that's beautiful
that's real beautiful let's take another
heaven call here we go hey Kenny some
courtesy faces what's up Kenny from
cutting shoot gagging brother homework I
was calling about that heaven man when
all the kids in church they called us
there you know heaven was confident
worshipped and oh no they're always
thought that sounded boring as hell when
I was a kid I thought having sounded
boring is for us but they say because it
was constant worship you know just like
we were already in church worship there
why we got to worship when we died - oh
yeah that's double worship man I feel
you there but now that I'm older I kind
of feel like heaven is a little more
specific to every person you know like
every person is having a different just
like every person held could be
different so that's it gonna go and feel
thank you bro yeah you know it would be
nice to think that it's set that it's
different then we only that we all get
our own that we all have one that's very
unique to us it would really make sense
almost because the world feels very
unique to us you know we said could we
we're only able to really get our own
perception of of life here on earth so
it'd be interesting it'd be probably
similar to really get that the same in
heaven you get the same you know that
your understanding of your environment
is specific to you yeah I don't know man
and I hope they have a hell - Brian I
hope there's a chance where you could
get you know if you don't you know Mon
your your taters and toss that they
could drag you back down the other end
of the hallway
it would just be exciting you know
that's one of the another thing that
maybe really keeps me believing in in in
another leg of our existence is just the
choice to have excitement for there to
be something else when people are like
oh man you die and and that's it and
like that's buddy could write that book
you know anybody could do that you know
I'd like to think that I'm built for
something more you know it may be a
selfish but I don't think there's
anything real selfish and thinking that
you would like to be able to exist more
to be able to have new experiences and
hopefully ones that are even better than
the ones that were already having here
what else do we have going on man I'm a
little you know I'm well as always I'm a
little tired that's just my mo we got a
patreon question came in Alaskan Rock
vodka are you planning on upping your
podcast frequency if we're gonna be shut
in with all this virus business we need
to get more online entertainment Thank
You Alaskan Rock vodka and thank you for
being a longtime patreon supporter
really from the beginning and and and I
really want to thank you very much real
kind of you yeah I think I'm gonna do
some stuff I'm gonna try my best you
know I don't want to just put out
whatever I want to be feeling good and
put out cool stuff we got Glen big baby
Davis coming in tomorrow and he went to
school at LSU and and I went to school
down there at LSU and and so I'm really
excited to see to have a conversation
with him who else we have some really
cool guests coming up and depending on
you know how the viral thing plays out
what we're gonna do what its going to be
like but you know we may have more we
may we're supposed to do a live this
past weekend in I want to say it's in
April or May out here in Los Angeles so
I think there's some options what else
that came in thank you for that question
though yeah we're gonna try to do some
stuff some extra King in the sting we're
also going to try to do some stuff for
the single moms that we have we know
this is a tough time for them having to
deal with you know probably just changes
you know maybe they're still working but
they need to find help for their
children so we're gonna reach out and do
something special for them try to help
out a little bit what else man that's it
dude a handle I will say this and now
you see a lot of lot of hair on the
ground people they cut in people's hair
and just leaving it people you know
somebody just drop a damn pigtail and
just it'll be right there another
question that came in how's it feel this
from action Jackson how does it feel to
be done with your dark arts tour is
there anything in particular you're
looking forward to doing now that you
have more free time yeah I'm looking to
take care of myself a little bit better
I'm looking to get some more rest you
know I'm working on a pilot project
right now with with Mike judge actually
and Greg Daniels who made beavis and
butt-head and some other stuff so I'm
excited about you know they really love
the animation that we've been putting up
on Instagram and thank you guys so much
for your support on that so we're
working on trying to take a project out
you know we'll pile it out so it's kind
of it's a little scary to talk about but
it's really I guess it's okay to talk
about you know I'm just really excited I
guess about it I'm hopeful I'm not like
overly excited I just want it to be you
know I love the little cartoon guy and I
love you know I just don't want to spoil
kind of what without what we already
have going on with it and so but I think
that you know those guys are obviously
legends and and it really makes me feel
amazing that they're excited and so
we'll see what happens
you know I'm just trying to stay
creative so I think those are things I'm
gonna do I'm just gonna try to stay
workers just try and make take care of
myself suck and be a little more
creative and stay creative what else try
and do some yoga and get some extra naps
you know I think it's I'm pretty lucky
that the tour some people's tours were
just starting and they're having a real
impact now but those are things that I'm
looking forward to doing so thanks for
asking that question man um here's a
question from Riley Mora and it says
gang why is Hawaii so comforting I've
never been but you make it seem like the
best get away take care of yourself I
think there's not like it's just
relaxing I can't here's why because
everything there's no real nightlife
there everything shuts down early so you
sometimes you'll feel a pressure like I
got to go out I got it people are doing
at 8 o'clock in Hawaii everybody's
eating dinner and it is bedtime and it
doesn't matter if you're 22 or if you're
51 so I think that's what it is just the
fact that it's okay to be at peace there
you know it's one thing it's almost a
similar like with this virus it's like
you know with this roan of people are
wondering you know or I'm feeling like
okay at least now we have an excuse to
just relax you know it's like okay we
can just chill you know oh you can look
across the table and see who someone is
see who who is that you know I'll get to
know my kid a little bit better I'll
break out a board game there is
something really comfortable man we've
been on this fast fast train in America
and it's nice to have just something
kind of apply this weird break I'm not
saying that this is a good break but I'm
just saying that it is there's something
really comforting in it I feel like in a
weird way to kind of know that people
are hopefully taking care of themselves
so that's one thing that's kind of neat
about this and that's one thing that's
neat about Hawaii is that there's just
that energy there there's that energy of
just self-care taking care of yourself
the ocean you know the more I would go
get in the ocean every day when I was
over there and I just kept feeling like
the world kept falling off my shoulders
like just the troubles that I had or the
problems or whatever you know the stress
kind of fell off my shoulder so that was
really nice to feel what else I think we
got into a lot of stuff you know we got
big baby Glen Davis coming in tomorrow
we got King and the sting on Tuesday a
lot of fun stuff going on and let's get
into one more call right here before we
cruise out okay yes I do she said you
said you liked the movie family man yes
ma'am I do
thank you with Nicholas Cage and I was
just wondering if if you were given a
glimpse of your life if you hadn't
become a comedian what would what would
you think that glimpse would would look
like yeah all right thank you
hmm if I hadn't become a comedian and
had to go have a glimpse of my life wow
that's a good question um well thanks
for the call uh you know I I feel like
maybe I would have been maybe done arts
and crafts maybe somebody did arts and
crafts instructor or you know maybe a
attorney maybe but just attorney because
you get to speak in front of people like
you got to like kind of prove a case or
talk discuss a point or something that's
one thing I think I remember wanting to
be when I was younger
mmm or you know what honestly I think I
really might have got into being a
writer you know I really like to write
you know when people used to write I
used to love it and now it's more typing
and stuff it's different but man I
really liked writing when it was popular
but yeah I think I don't know how I
wonder what a glimpse of my life would
be like I'd probably be and I don't know
I'd probably be you know my brother's a
pretty good role model so I probably
learned from some stuff from him so I
bet I would have probably ended up being
maybe an attorney or a writer maybe both
and I bet I would have had a marriage
but I would have probably gotten a
divorce because I've never really been
ready for it yet you know just kind of
part of you know never really hard to
keep my you know my mind out of out of
the cookie jar or whatever and yeah I
think that that would be it
maybe no kids yet or maybe a child but
yeah that's a good question
oh it's a good question um what else did
we get into a lot of stuff this week I
don't even know I don't even know I'm
glad to be back though but man I miss it
at the same time you know I just there's
something I they they you know there was
fear people are worried that they're
they might shut down air travel
everywhere so I said I got to get back
home and I got to get back to the
podcast and I'm been in here so I was
just said we need to do it and
we did it and this is it I want to thank
everybody for communicating I want to
thank everybody for being a part of the
of the podcast and just of what's going
on and yeah we're get into some extra
stuff this week we'll keep putting out
some good content and and doing our best
as always hit the hotline nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
if something is going on in your
universe and what will take us out
tonight oh I know what we'll do we'll do
some North Mississippi Allstars with
drunk outdoors
yeah stay aware you know we'll stay
aware we do what we can you know this is
a unique time in existence where we get
to see who we are inside of ourselves
you know I think it's neat we can learn
a lot about ourselves and and and really
find ways to try and just be decent to
one another but it's a wild time you
know there's a lot of shockers rockin
out there and and thank you guys for for
showing up this week and I'll see you
guys again next week and I'll see you
this week with a Glen big baby Davis be
good to yourselves and I'm gonna try to
do the same gang
[Music]
well then I gotta try
Gogi drunk out
[Music]
it's wrong
go get drunk outdoors
[Music]
got money
get that hitter
[Music]
you guys can go check that soon out if
you want
that's drunk outdoors by the North
Mississippi Allstars and take care of
your sails get some rest and and I'll
see you guys next week okay